peu
[Musique]
enfin en face est parti et avec lui mais
soirée de folie pour salino bleuté reste
chez moi crochet dans l'entré nuit
brésilienne
enfin paris c'était la folie les étoiles
du ciel à meylan
bonjour lumière
[Musique]
si bien sur lesquels paris
c'est la folie des latins
jusqu'au petit matin on est plein
les partis pour voyager
il n'a pas terrassé soulier oui nous
californie
il ne sait toujours pas où il fera
sombre nuit brésilienne
paris c'était la folie les étoiles du
ciel semaine
on joue lumière un peu de
bien sûr les quais parisiens
c'est la folle idée
jusqu'au petit matin on est bien
[Musique]
du
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il reviendra comme le corcovado les bras
en croix
il me demande
où est ce qu'on va pour danser la samba
et on ira
pour manger des glaces on fera le brésil
la nuit près
c'est de la folie c'est la folie telle
atteint
jusqu'au petit matin on est bien
[Musique]
m